hello who's there hi hello hi what's
your name Jerry Jerry and where you from
Jay originally from Ireland but I live
in other loving you if they're loving
you
whereabouts in Ireland a small town
called Mullingar County Westmeath what
do you do I'm a graphic designer
a graphic designer by God he's left
Ireland in the dust off we go with the
story
well my story happened in Dublin back in
their 90's and one night I was out
clubbing and I hooked up with this guy
and things are getting a little bit hot
so we go back to my house I'm at my
house things get a little bit hotter and
clothes start to come off etc etc and
and we're both left in our underwear and
he wants me to rip his underwear off so
I think okay I'll try so I try it won't
come off and I try it then they won't
come off so I think I know I have a
brilliant idea so I go to the kitchen
and I get the sharpest knife I can find
and then come back to that better knife
and hand as you do and I go to do the
deed and as I do the knife goes straight
through his underwear and goes straight
into my leg so I have knife hello my
name and I have to be rushed to a splint
the cut was so deep that they can't
stitch it so there I had to go to
hospital every day for a full month to
get the dressing and fix until it healed
oh yeah and confession to this day I
never actually told my family what
really happened
[Applause]
yeah I bet they had sex before we went
to the hospital
hello what's your name my name is Dean
Dean
lovely that what do you do Dean I'm an
assistant accountant at assistant
accountant Oh
he holds the calculator mention one of
our nose films say you like it and it'll
go very well for you okay so my story's
about autocorrect and so I woke up one
morning I wasn't feeling very well so I
decided that text my manager and tell
her wasn't gonna be it well this could
be good so I sent the message and I said
I'm not gonna be in today I'm not
feeling very well I've been up vomiting
all night I had five guys last night and
I'm a mess this morning
the bagger chain yeah so she takes me
back and said this is some kind of jokes
I don't think it's funny so I was really
confused so I read the message back and
my phone had autocorrected vomiting -
bottoming hello hello now because I met
you before the show I know your name is
Sinead yes yes yes I remembered that I'm
he's as well Frank alright we're about
to Knology from its time from kaity
doing countdown okay
I wouldn't even try Regina just let this
story wash over you I was going to
America for a summer for our work
placement and I was having to find
obviously somewhere to live I was in New
York so in New York being like London
very expensive and the places I was
finding were about 600-700 point yeah
but then I came across this one piece
that was 99 quid for a month and I
thought well it's been cheap but you
know might be doable and I had my own
room you know there was a bathroom
but at the end of the like adverted said
light housekeeping Judy's and I thought
oh my god what I'd be living in a light
house did some research but thought you
know what I have to do some exams like
do you have to do a course to be a
lighthouse keeper excited - my dad he
was super excited about it my mom came
over to read it she goes auction it you
wouldn't be a lighthouse keeper it's not
light housekeeping Judy's its light
housekeeping
[Applause]
I know those gonna be much worse story I
thought yeah I started I was gonna have
sex with a guy he lived
now housekeeping that's not a phrase I
know but it's just like housekeeping a
delightful new euphemism oh you better
keep this light house hello hello hi
what's your name
well will lovely and what do you do will
an IT consultant sorry sorry okay so a
couple years ago when Jack started to
get a bit famous
I'm loving this Netflix specials galore
in the autumn I found myself single and
then I started to mingle and what I
discovered when I was mingling was that
apparently through the berry mists and
beer drinking of women in Essex I
somehow apparently look a bit like white
thank you my friend
it's been
[Applause]
[Applause]
someone didn't say to me once they came
up to me and went don't take this the
wrong way but you look like Jack
Whitehall hello
you saved me I was like holding on to
the chair let's see how the chemistry is
this time okay hello
[Music]
all right let's try one more one more
here we go here we go will we know I let
her okay I'd let her go
what oh let her go go Oh talk talk no I
like oh you're oh he has to sit you
Jaden wants to hear your story brilliant
okay what's your name my name is Tammy
Tammy and where you from Tammy and from
Hammersmith and what do you do I work in
marketing marketing okay off you go
[Applause]
hi who are you I'm Reina hello and what
do you do for a living I work as a
consultant in an IT company okay I
thought I thought we were gonna be a
medical consultant I thought you really
shouldn't be doing this
no wants to see you in an office in
Harley Street tomorrow yeah okay off you
go with this story yep
I'm from a South Indian family I had an
arranged marriage so I was given choices
when I met the first guy the first
question that I asked him was have you
watched friends and he had no idea about
the show there was a huge letdown for me
so I had to reject him my mom thought I
was crazy to be making life decisions
over this the very next guy that I met
he was a huge friend's fan we really hit
it off and he proposed to me the same
way as how Chandler proposed to Monica
the same unfortunately he couldn't be
here because he's babysitting our
daughter
[Applause]
hi hi the bar is very low
hi I'm Kate Kate lovely we're from Kate
I'm from London London and what you do
case I'm a teacher I'm a geography
teacher okay off you go we do story so
I'm in Egypt on a scuba diving trip my
friend and I on day two come down with
Egypt's belly unfortunately so scuba
diving is out of the question but we
want to make the most of our trip we
decide to head to the beach for a bit of
sunbathing well meant Sun Lounger and
unexpectedly out of the blue I have a
bit of an accident in my bikini so I'm
laying on my son now Joe what am I gonna
do here and I decided I'm gonna grab a
towel I'm gonna waddle my way down to
the sea I'm going to immerse myself
slowly into the water nobody's gonna be
any wiser
except I hadn't factored in the fact
that there is a whole coral reef of fish
and there ensues a feeding frenzy injury
there are lots and lots of Russian and
Chinese tourists who to think it's a
wonderful photo opportunity
[Applause]
teacher
[Applause]
[Music]
you